and he points at her and so she like
went to go move it and that's when you
just hear the loud bang and a little bit
of a light and then she
drops and next thing you know she just
starts to bleed okay okay I really
didn't want things to AC like this this
sucks I'm so sorry did you say anything
else to her did she say anything to you
or no no she just screamed she just
[Music]
screamed it's not just adult offenders
that police deal with on a daily basis
juveniles they also pop up on law
enforcement's Radars we're breaking down
six times children were the ones in
handcuffs welcome to after hours
presented by law and crime I'm Sam
[Music]
Goldberg we begin in Miami Florida where
13-year-old Derek Rosa is being detained
in an adult facility for allegedly
stabbing his mother more than 40 times
according to police Rosa himself called
911 on October 12th to report he had
killed his own mother 39-year-old Arena
Garcia in their apartment Garcia had
just given birth to Rosa's little sister
14 days before the baby was asleep near
Garcia's bed when Rosa allegedly walked
into the room and stabbed his mother
recently released photos show images
from the baby monitor in the room in one
Garcia is lounging on the bed with the
baby
in the next shot Rosa can be seen
standing over his mother the baby was
unharmed and apparently sleeping during
the violent assault I need to know if
your mom is is breathing she said
Miss okay what did you do that blood all
over the floor Rosa tells the dispatcher
he had considered using his stepfather's
gun to kill himself but couldn't bring
himself to do it the eighth grader also
tells the dispatcher he sent photos of
what he'd done to a friend Miss
yes I took pictures and I told my
friends about it was that bad you told
who about it my friend who did you send
us pictures to my friend I don't know
his real name cuz he is online friend
play with a lot according to court
documents Rosa took two photos of his
mother's body as well as a selfie and
sent it to the friend Rosa is charged as
an adult with first-degree murder he has
pleaded not guilty the 13-year-old was
most recently in court in mid December
where the judge her testimony over 2
days on whether Rosa should remain in
the adult detention center or if he
should be moved to a juvenile facility
also during a December 14th hearing a
detective testified about multiple
pieces of damning evidence against Rosa
including his police interview in the
hours after the homicide was discovered
by you signing that you're wanting to
give us a statement without the presence
of a lawyer you understand that is that
your wish yes my wish okay so you went
to sleep around 10: 10 okay and then
what I woke up I went to the kitchen I
grabbed one of the kitchen knives and
then I went to her room and then I
ate it's okay you can say I kill you you
killed her Rosa sounds very calm on the
video but cries in court as he listens
to himself played back Rosa grandmother
was also emotional when she heard Rose's
apparent confession and admission that
he had con considered suicide did you
ever make your way to your
sister killing her no touching her
touching her no no I left her alone she
was sleeping and she didn't wake up so I
didn't touch her
okay all right uh let's get back to your
mom okay you said she was sleeping yes
okay where exactly did you cut
her at first I cut her right here and
her neck is like a type of vein that go
goes through your neck right here on
both sides and if you stab here lot of
blur sprs out right do you know what
that that's called like an artery or
something an artery yeah okay and and um
you purposely went for the artery when
you cut it not purposely I just went for
the neck but I hadit the AR okay was
there a lot of blood after there's a big
part of Blood on the floor
okay um did you tell her anything before
you stabbed
her did you say anything curse in
Spanish curse words in Spanish yes but
she didn't wake up when you she was
asleeping she was asleep when you
stabbed her yes and then she woke up
after I stabbed her what curse words did
you say in Spanish yes uh
Mara R yes
okay um and then she woke up yes did you
say anything else to her did she say
anything to you or no no she just
screaming she just screamed yes
okay
um why did you stab your mom can I go to
the bathroom before I answer that yes of
course one of the officers takes Rosa to
the restroom then brings him back a few
minutes later they ask a few other
questions then get back to motive so you
were about to tell me the why why did
you uh Kill Your Mother do you
know do I have to say a
noun yeah get it off your chest
absolutely can
friender okay at this point you want a
lawyer the interview ends there but the
investigation was just beginning
detectives were able to get a search
warrant to look at Rose's phone they
then found multiple Google searches from
the night of the murder the first one he
typed in the word the kateed artery
image Di diagram okay and
and after that what is the best place to
stab someone okay what's
next is a small knife good for killing
what's
next is it easier to kill someone with a
small knife what's
next can a knife cut through bone and
the last one it was an image of a lmg
machine gun okay information from the
autopsy pointed at the brutality of the
crime is it fair to say that there were
46 sharp for ones in total on Miss's you
46 46 sir
yes at the end of the two-day hearing
the judge determined Rosa would stay at
Metro West Detention Center the adult
facility until his murder trial so I
think it's pretty clear from watching
after hours as I know everyone does
every single week the world isn't always
always the safest place it's important
to realize if you're ever seriously hurt
your injury could actually be worth
millions that's where Morgan and Morgan
a proud sponsor of after hours comes in
Morgan and Morgan doesn't just settle
for lowball offers in the past couple
months they've seen verdicts of 12
million in Florida 26 million in
Philadelphia and 6.8 million in New York
and here's the kicker the fee is
absolutely free unless you win you can
start your claim with America's largest
injury law firm in just a single click
on your phone they've completely
modernized the injury law process so you
can submit a claim and communicate with
your legal Team all from your phone you
don't even have to leave your couch to
do so so to start your claim now with
Morgan and Morgan go to ww.
forthepeople.com
hours or click the link in the
description and in the pinned
comments next we're heading to New
Mexico where a 14-year-old boy is
accused of shooting and killing a fellow
teen and he's not the only only one in
serious legal trouble it's July 28th
2023 in Questa New Mexico just north of
Santa Fe according to police four
juveniles were inside the suspect's
house listening to music when suddenly
the 14-year-old pulled out a gun and
shot a 13-year-old girl the victim's
family identified her as Amber
archuletta when First Responders and
police get to the home it's chaotic EMTs
work to try and save archeleta while
officers try to work out exactly what
had happened you
here you said you do have a full fuck
out fucking window some
shit proceed to the of she
alive is I
can she still she still has a pulse
archuleta's brother was also at the home
when she was shot he's now frantic
begging First Responders for details on
his sister's condition and I I'm going
to have to ask you bro what you're doing
right now is not helping I'm going to
need you to go sit down over here or
just give us a second okay you don't
need to be upset I understand it's your
S I understand but what you're doing
right now is I understand but what
you're doing right now is not helping
okay I'm not trying to be I'm not trying
to I'm trying to help you buddy okay
this what you're doing right now isn't
helping please go over there with do
doing much well here's here's the thing
dude the Medics are on the way all we
can all we can try to do is is keep
alive while the Medics
are she is she has a pulse so you need
it's it's pretty good so can you please
just go over there and let us do our job
please it's okay it's okay butd I
understand you're upset I totally get it
okay we're going to we're going to need
you to back up please please please guys
being here is not going to help believe
me let us do our job I understand you
love her we're going to do everything we
possibly can to help her okay I promise
you at first officers are told the girl
was outside on the street in front of
the home and might have been the victim
of a driveby shooting they start
searching for evidence along the road
but not long after archuletta is
pronounced dead and the home is now a
murder
scene okay so we got to shut it shut it
down clear the scene cop is Dow
um let's get some tape and start taping
everything off tape everything off put
the unit in the road I want to block off
whatever we can after getting multiple
conflicting stories the truth starts to
come to light a witness tells law
enforcement that a group of friends was
inside 14 y- old poerio Brown's house
just hanging out but he suddenly pulled
out a gun and pointed it at archuleta's
face was it a 22 what kind of revolver
do you don't know you just know that you
just know that it was a revolver handgun
right yeah I know was one of those the
best been got
you
okay and he pointed it at her and she
wants to go like like take it away from
her face right all of a sudden you just
hear a boom I look and I see her fall to
the ground next see you know she starts
to bleed so he shot her in the face with
with the handgun yeah I where where
where were you guys when he shot her
with the handgun um I think uh the
kitchen you guys were inside the house
when happened yeah and he points at her
and so she like went to go move it m and
that's when you just hear the loud bang
and a little bit of a light and then she
drops and next thing you know she just
starts to bleed okay okay Witnesses
later tell police it was Brown's idea to
say it was a drive by shooting as
officers are processing the scene
archuleta's father arrives and learns
his daughter is dead body camera footage
then captures the heartbreaking moment
hi sir I understand sir can you talk to
me for just a couple
minutes um the EMS just pronounced her
deceased oh my God
man gone what he's
G can I please go here
yes I'll have one of my guys meet you
I'm trying to stay out here to block
this off yeah I'm fine I'm fine I'm
fine 404 406 you have the father walking
in now uh he's got a carpenter knee pads
on a blue t-shirt and a baseball cap I'm
sorry sir my my condolences I thank I'm
honestly I'm going to do my damnest to
figure out what happened I I'm sorry I I
don't know but my son called me
a oh God I didn't know I can't
be the suspect's father William Brown is
also at the home and at first he tries
to stick with the driveby shooting story
but police have already determined that
didn't happen and that the 14-year-old
is involved what are you taking him to a
unit what unit well did you bringing the
unit to the house Main Street for
what for what that's what I'm that's all
DET he's being detained at this time I
think it's pretty obvious he's being
detained well that but what he didn't do
nothing yes he's being detained I didn't
see he's being arrested he's beain with
us that's that's it that's going to be
in the end of it okay he's not leaving
they R he's just going to you guys can't
bring him to the house the unit to the
house cuz it's a c I can't I can't let
anyone in there so that's the other
thing how long is this going to take as
long as it takes I don't I can't give
you an answer cuz it I know but what are
you how long is this going to take cuz
you know we don't have
12 I just got to hold on to you okay we
don't have another place to go that
better I mean I you appreciate that
there's a dead girl on your porch right
yeah I don't have an option either so
you know where to go but I don't have an
option the police then take Port forio
Brown into custody you okay okay I love
you okay they ain't got nothing on me I
ain't worried where they they ain't got
nothing on me cuz I ain't do nothing
it's okay just keep your mouth quiet we
have a lawyer it's going to be okay but
you're going to have to drink something
I can't bro my wrists are all getting
cut into down you have to settle down
you have to be calm right now okay my
wrists are getting cut into it's okay
here for I know you're arrested I can't
do anything about that at first
authorities say William Brown did
nothing wrong except being
confrontational with police and don't
not s up with him stop stop I'm not just
well he Stu what do you expect you have
a dead girl in your like you not
understand the severity of this I do go
that way I've been trying to cooperate
with the cop hold on hold on well
they're taking him he said I could walk
with you guys yes you need to calm down
I am your off I wasn't even talking to
them and I just told him to leave so he
didn't aggravate you anymore but you
can't keep doing this cuz then I'll put
you in cuffs and I don't want to do that
you done nothing wrong but eventually
William Brown is arrested for allowing
his teenage son easy access to weapons
in the home there's a lot of guns in
that house right and none of them are
secured uh most of them are secured I
have a few that are out you have a few
that are out okay with that with that
right there have your hands put your
hand on your back despite more than a
Dozen guns being found in the Home
Police have never found the murder
weapon William Brown is now charged
under New Mexico's Benny's law it's
named after Benny Hargrove an
Albuquerque middle schooler shot and
killed by a fellow student the gunman
allegedly used his father's gun to
commit the crime Brown is charged with
second-degree murder and tampering with
evidence Brown was released from a
juvenile detention center and allowed to
live with his grandparents until trial
Brown can have supervised visits with
his dad but they can't talk about the
case if he's found guilty the teen could
get up to 18 years in an adult
prison next we go to Tulsa Oklahoma it's
just before midnight on Thursday January
5th 2023 and Tulsa Police have been
called out to a troubling
report responding to the stabbing the
calling 12-year-old daughter stabbed
night one of the first officers on the
scene runs into an apartment where EMTs
are working on a 9-year-old boy in in
the living room the officer locates the
young suspect and takes her outside the
home where's your daughter she's
upstairs J get down
here where's the knife at I don't even
know what
she jayen I'm so sorry I'm so come here
come here I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry we're just going to
put handcuffs on just for now the
12-year-old girl who isn't identified
because of her age is inconsolable
where's the I'm sorry I don't know
what I'm sorry I'm sorry please I'm so
sorry how old are you I'm 12 years old
where's the
knife I was upstairs in my room and I
threw it out the window and it's behind
the apartment right here you threw it
where I threw it out my window behind
the I'm so sorry Mama I'm so sorry I
don't know what happened it's some so
sorry I got to go with him I'm so sorry
I don't know what the happened I don't
know what happened I don't know what
happened while the boy is rushed to a
hospital police try to figure out if
anyone else is inside the apartment it's
just me my mom and my
brother he's dying while the girl
continues to say she doesn't know what
happened she does know that she's in
serious trouble I really didn't want
things to happen like this this sucks
I'm I'm so sorry and probably going to
go to jail and going to live the rest of
my life in prison while the suspect is
detained other officers begin to sweep
the house what would possess a
12-year-old little girl to stab a little
TW I mean there's a picture of them
right there on the wall that girl's got
to be all kinds of messed up got to be
some
issues officers put the girl in front of
a squad car while her hands are cuffed
behind her back a Tulsa officer then sat
with her and did his best to keep keep
her calm occasionally he would get out
of the car to talk on the phone and the
girl would talk to
herself I'm so sorry God please help me
I just want to wake up from this
nightmare Sorry
God I'm so sorry God the officer tried
to keep the girl's mind off of what was
happening all around her talking about
school sports video games and the recent
Christmas holiday but the 12-year-old
often broke down I know it's hard right
now I'm just take a deep breath you know
I ruined my life I ruined my own future
no nobody's ruined life okay all
right it's all my fault fine fine it's
no Le's fault okay it's nobody's fault
the seventh grader also wants to know if
she'll be able to go back to her school
before she goes to jail I just want to
say goodbye to a lot of
people say good where you
going St up to someone that's bad that's
really bad let's not think about that
okay I don't even know if my mom will
want me to live there
anymore your mom loves you okay your
brother loves you tooon trust me anymore
what are you talking about they wouldn't
be able to just me anymore what I did
they would probably be too scared to
even let me back in the house while the
girl was in the car her mother was
speaking with a different officer at the
hospital where her son was undergoing
surgery 12-year-old daughter I don't
understand why she would do something
like that she's T I cannot imagine what
you're going through right now she's
never been aggress of anything it's not
like her like it's like they bully each
other like brother and sisters but it's
never they never like like fits fine or
do anything like that was just he was in
bed it was downstairs trying to sleep I
don't know why she even went down there
like what the hell was she I don't
understand any of it all I know is I
heard him screaming like the worst
scream ever and I thought maybe he was
having a nightmare so I started try to
wake him up and there's blood everywhere
and he said she stabbed me she stabbed
me I was like
who and he started go get it out of
Consciousness and so that's when they
told me to put them on the floor and do
chest compressions and
and I couldn't find my daughter anywhere
was screaming her name and she ran out
after she did it cuz she was scared and
she's not a bad kid like she doesn't do
bad thing you know what I mean like she
doesn't in trouble it was weird yeah the
mother reveals that her son typically
doesn't sleep downstairs but she allowed
him to that night I should have told him
no he asked if he can sleep downstairs
and I said yes I wish I would have said
no well there's nothing don't blame your
there's nothing that you could have done
differently really tell him no and this
night I was like yeah
fine I I mean there's nothing that you
could have done differently I mean don't
blame yourself for any of this I didn't
protect him I didn't know what she was
going to do so I didn't know I supposed
to know I know but I feel like I didn't
protect him like his home he's supposed
to feel
safe around 2:30 a.m. the 9-year-old
died from his wounds the 12-year-old
suspect was taken to the Tulsa County
Family Center for Juvenile Justice to
meet with detectives and be reunited
with her mom because of the age of the
suspect police in the district
attorney's office have been tight lipped
about the case her mother told media
Outlets that her daughter had some kind
of manic episode that may have been
related to a medication it's unknown
What charges if any will be
filed next we're back in Florida this
time it's Port Orange that's where
police arrested an 11-year-old child for
apparently prank texting 911 it's
Wednesday July 26th 2023 a dispatcher
with the Sheriff's Office got a message
around 9:45 a.m. about a suspicious
incident reported by text message the
texts were from a girl saying her
14-year-old friend had been kidnapped by
someone in a white van she said the
person had a gun and was traveling on
I95 she also told the dispatcher she was
in a blue Jeep following the alleged
kidnapper the Sheriff's Office says the
girl continued to communicate with
dispatchers for an hour and a half
multiple officers from at least three
different agencies responded to the
location the girl provided and the
Sheriff's Office helicopter even joined
the search but when law enforcement
couldn't find the van or a suspect they
Trac the messages back to the girl's
home in Port Orange body camera video
shows her in
handcuffs stay calm you can talk to your
parents we can open the window and let
you talk to them nothing's going to
happen to you do you understand that
okay the girl's father was home when
deputies showed up and told his daughter
that she better learn from from this I'm
telling you this right now you're going
to take this as a lesson at 11 years old
that if you do something stupid in the
future you're going to enjoy those cuffs
I'm not going to do this again deputies
then charged the 11-year-old with making
a false police report concerning using a
firearm in a violent Manner and misuse
of 911 this is going to be an
opportunity for you to turn this into a
learning experience this is not
something you're going to carry with you
for the rest of your life okay she told
deputies she got the idea to prank 911
from a YouTube video and thought it
would be funny the girl was taken to the
Family Resource Center for processing
then transferred to the regional
Juvenile Detention Center in Daytona
Beach she was eventually released to her
parents and is on a house
arrest now we're staying in Florida this
time in Riverview outside of Tampa
that's where 14-year-old adem Barry
faced adult charges of murder on August
16th 2023 around 4 in the afternoon
Hillsboro County deputies got calls
about a young male running through a
subdivision with a handgun things were
tense as soon as deputies arrived Barry
reportedly put the gun to his head
multiple times and threatened to kill
himself I don't want to hurt you bro I
do not want to shoot you put it down you
don't want to end it this way you don't
want to end it this way brother I
promise you whatever happened today it
can be fixed don't pull the trigger put
it down law enforcement then used a
non-lethal launcher to knock the gun out
of Barry's hand the deputy got emotional
as he encouraged the teenager to leave
the gun on the ground all the way up in
the air keep walking toward me the only
one keep walking toward me keep hadim
come on buddy don't retreat come back
this way come toward me man come toward
me my gun is only out cuz I don't know
what you're going to do please don't
pick that back up I got you I got you
dog I'm telling you I got you the deputy
promises to put his own weapon away once
the teen cooperates I'm going have you
do is I'm going to have you lay down in
the grass lay down in the grass lay down
in the grass lay down in the grass lay
down in the grass watch lay all the way
down my gun is going in its holster it's
at this point that the officer finds out
the boy's age how old you
look 14 who did you
shoot
Avi you
shoot it took the officer about 16
minutes to fully deescalate the
situation you could hear fellow law
enforcement calling for EMS they found
Barry's mother's boyfriend with five
guns shot wounds he survived but Barry's
mother Tiffany Harris was found dead in
a driveway Barry's brother later told
police he saw Barry shoot their mother
inside the home and ran away to save
himself Barry was charged with murder in
the second degree attempted murder in
the first degree and aggravated assault
with a deadly weapon after evaluations
the Court ruled Barry is currently
incompetent to stand trial he was
remanded to the Department of Children
and Families to be placed in a mental
health facility Barry is later deemed
competent ident he could stand
trial we end today's episode in ovita
Florida that's where police came under
Fire for handcuffing a 9-year-old boy at
an elementary school it happened on
February 2nd 2023 two Ovito officers
responded to reports of a quote unruly
child s up for me
bud
s me so you C down this is where we he
can do that cuz he's on the road just
calm you down for a second chill
chill stop
it stop it sit
up the child can be seen on body camera
footage throwing paper and books as
staff members try to get him to calm
down the officers don't have much more
luck don't you want to throw stuff
though
right you that's okay I get that a lot
it doesn't hurt my feelings one of the
officers then puts the child in
handcuffs saying in their incident
report that they did it because they
feared for the safety of the people
around
them until you C down this is where
we're at he can do that he's on the road
just calm you down for a second
according to the police report the
handcuffs were dangled Loosely on the
child's wrists but kept his hands inside
the handcuffs however didn't keep the
9-year-old from screaming stop
it stop it sit
up chill chill just
relax need to
chill
you st we can take the hand shut up
despite the repeated curse words the
officers try to get the fourth grader to
calm down you're throwing things you're
putting
everyone you need to hear it you it's
okay I get that a lot we're trying to
figure out
upset stop pulling stop stop
pulling stop picking out my
hand relax holding me if you relax we
can talk to you and you can shut the up
that's why you're not going
anywhere you know in another situation
you would be very big trouble for
hitting a police officer shut up just
letting you know the older you get it's
going to be very harder for you to be
these
behaviors you're doing really good with
officer tenant she gives you stickers
she sees she asks you how your day is
and then this is how you treat us
yeah the officers also tell him that the
way he's acting could have serious
consequences you don't care but you can
go to jail for things like that and I
don't want to see you go to jail for
things like that
okay you can get you can get in trouble
for hitting staff
too okay I've done it since fre K that's
not nice why do you do those
things because
teacher but why they're only trying to
teach you okay a few minutes later a
teacher is seen speaking with the
student which seems to calm him down an
officer then removes the
handcuffs thanks
bud good
job shortly after the student was taken
to the guidance counselor's office the
boy's family has filed a lawsuit against
the city of Ido they claimed the
officer's actions were unnecessary and
unreasonable the school district would
not comment on the pending litigation
thanks for watching for Law and crime
after hours I'm Sam
[Music]
Goldberg